claire's with us in Nashville hi Claire
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you so I was just wondering what is the
best way to go off about paying off a
very high interest rate credit card when
the minimum payment is already very high
I just I feel like I'm throwing a lot of
money at a card each month for the
balance to only go down a little bit and
I you know I tried transferring to a
card with 0% interest rate for 18 months
which helps but I wasn't able to put as
much toward it as I wanted to at the
time and now that about 18-month window
is up I mean it is paid off but I'm just
not sure if I should consolidate try
transferring to another card with a low
interest rate I what's the best way to
go about that your doctor on the dodge
is 16 different ways you can't dodge it
kiddo you got to hit it head-on
how much do you owe on this card 5500
what's your income of forty five
thousand you're single yes I am okay and
what other debts what other debts do you
have um I have a car payment which I
wasn't expecting after my car got stolen
it was it was paid off so this was kind
of something I had you didn't have
insurance no I did have insurance it was
totaled when it was stolen and I give
you a check what can you buy a car for
that that doesn't necessitate a
qualified I should have I was trying to
get back the kind of car that I had and
it was just so I have eight thousand on
that which my minimum payment I'm not
gonna let you drop by that for your sake
okay
oh you did not get back to the level of
car you had the level of car you had you
got a check for you upgraded in car
that's how you got payments so I just
wanna make sure you own that for your
sake because that was a stupid move now
how much do you owe on this car I about
six thousand left okay so you fifty-five
hundred and six thousand what other
debts do you have that is it good okay
how old are you 24 and you're working
forty hours a week
what good for you okay the reason your
credit card is not going away
is not the interest rate the reason is
is you haven't made it your exclusive
Heol you have to hate these two debts
with such a level of anger that your
friends your broke friends think you've
lost your mind because you are doing
nothing nothing
they're hounding this debt you're not
going out to eat you're not going out on
a vacation you're not going with them on
their weekend bachelor bachelorette
party you're not doing anything
you are broke and $11,000 in debt you
have to get so freakin focused that like
if you didn't pay this off in four or
five months like you were going to die
or something I mean you got to get crazy
land about this you have not made this a
priority you can wander into debt you
cannot wander out and you're gonna have
to raise your level of intensity and
your level of focus then beyond a
written budget and you probably gonna
pick up an extra job you're probably
gonna sell some stuff and you're not
going to have a life until you get
eleven thousand five hundred dollars
where the debt paid off and the good
news is you can do that in about six
months but you're going to have no life
for six months and that probably means
picking up an extra job I don't know
Chris what else are you seeing there
yeah I just work a budget like your
pretend like you're making thirty
thousand a year and work that thirty
thousand dollar budget and just like in
sports analogy just for those listening
in for that play sports you leave the
locker room and you get this anger
inside of you for the opponent you just
want to absolutely drill them in the
teeth when it comes to football or
whatever sport I don't know what the
hell that translates into you clean your
world clear but get that angry maybe it
was a brother or sister that frustrated
the mess a TIA and get that angry at it
and attack it debt consolidation only
does what that elimination really does
the debt consolidation wants to do it
but it can't you want to make sure
you're doing debt elimination not debt
consolidation yeah and show you okay
$11,000 11,500 I'll versus thousand
dollars a month for 12 months and you're
done or it's $2,000 a month for six
months and you're done and that's the
way you start to look at it and that's
the level of intensity I want you
somewhere in that $2,000 range but
that's going to mean an extra job that's
going to mean selling stuff and that's
going to mean really really tight budget
and I'm promising you your broke friends
are gonna think you're weird and if
you're willing to do that that's how you
get rid of this card there is no program
where you can borrow your way out of
debt there's not one it doesn't work
there's not a low enough interest rate
that causes you to not care and just
kind of play with it and that's what you
did you just pushed it around you hit
you put you try to hide the P and it
shows up under one of those shells like
that shell game where you're hiding the
P and it keeps showing up and that's
what you did here so and then the next
time you have some kind of a crisis
don't borrow your way out of the crisis
oh by the way get that credit card out
and cut it up it's time for plastic
surgery that things not been a blessing
to you you need to have you need to have
your debit card only and that'll keep
you from going into debt any further
while you're doing this no matter what
happens you have to find a way to deal
with it without that because you know
you're 24 and you've already slipped
into 11,500 bucks worth and you slipped
into it it wasn't like this bold
declaration of debt it was boom there I
am I'm in a mess hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you